[Applause]
yo you wanna know some weird [ __ ] bro
yeah you look like bella thorne i do
look like bella thorne
what else but this is some weird [ __ ]
usually i'm not into pregnancy porn
all right when it starts when it starts
like that i i mean
usually i'm not all right i'm not into
that
but adam 22's girl
lena posted an instagram
where she's pregnant and looking hot
sweet girl lovely girl love lena but
she's looking hot
pregnant bro she's in like some lingerie
is that foul to be into your friend's
pregnant
wife girl whatever yeah i don't think i
don't think you can nah
i think we're not close enough where i
can say that
i'm not gonna talk about his girl but we
could talk about the concept of that
i mean she's posting it that's the other
thing
she's posting it are we talking about
this one
no that's a little real al come on
getting the pictures on it's the most
latest one it's the latest one it's like
a little video or like a gif you could
put it up i think we should objectively
talk about this because
i've been that's the one category of
pornography
that i do not [ __ ] with wait there's gay
porn
dude well if they can get pregnant then
there's a real [ __ ] problem
that's the only getting this all right
the only category of
male female there's incest porn
i'm okay with that all right because
it's fake can we show this
yeah we can show that i mean she posts
it on her instagram
i mean you have to admit
son she got some adele's right there bro
and now i can't get past the belly
protruding like she giving birth to mark
can't do it yo i can't do it yo
that's your fifth bullet bro yes it
dawg i have two is i got yeah i got two
extra balls he's been reloaded
so i can't believe you're gonna not
shoot him for sure i mean i got the
camera in the way al handle business
i already done shot all his man stop it
do something
nah but he cheated i can't unsee that
she
took a train by like five dudes or some
[ __ ] like that that's what you can't
unsee
like wait a minute what what you trained
by five dudes so recently like uh
ack and her boyfriend they got into a
little battle
adam 22. yeah um and act exposed some
details that she
had a train ran on her by believe it was
five dudes
for money or something or what for i
mean was it for a porn
maybe maybe it was like she's a sex
worker right that's what she does
any guy that's dating a porn star if you
try to insult him with
guys that his girl is [ __ ] it doesn't
work because she gets
[ __ ] for money exactly on camera
because she's in porn
exactly so that's not shocking the thing
that was shocking to me is usually i do
not
like pregnancy porn or anything like
that i haven't looked at any pregnancy
porn that's the one thing i do not click
on
i do not know all i know is in this one
image on instagram
what what
there's no maternity leave and only fans
that's funny that's why that's
disrespectful
we should say something oh my god okay
that being said
thank god some of these girls don't do
that because there are guys that are
into the pregnancy porn
i won't even allow myself to indulge in
have you ever watched one i can't do it
you don't watch it have you ever watched
one out be honest be honest
honestly i don't know you didn't even
put the cursor in front of the video
where it gives a little highlight [ __ ]
you didn't do that you just scrub
through you didn't do no scrub
nah mark to pull it up what have you
watched any pregnancy porn i
viewed it but i haven't used it as a as
a masturbatory device
yeah until completion what did you do
you just slap your dick on your [ __ ]
foot
[Laughter]
oh
i'm all out now oh god
so nice that someone else has something
big on their head besides me in this
round
okay in all seriousness you enjoyed it
or you did it purely for research
purposes mark
uh mostly research but i'm not
necessarily turned off by it
why not because to me i'm thinking like
back in the day especially when people
were
i was looking like like when the waiter
brings the plate and you said no onions
and there's just onions all over
come on wait this whole time for the
[ __ ]
sound you got a goddamn stuff how you
start with cap
mainly for research i like research
everyone knows that about me bro
if there was a wikipedia for the porn i
would have read it okay
but they don't really have that feature
okay go go
what are you doing i'm not doing
anything go but
tell us tell us tell us you're not
reloading right i'm not reloading all
right
tell us so basically like i'm thinking
back in the day you would have a bunch
of kids with your wife right
and you and your wife you'd have a bunch
of kids and because of that she'd be
pregnant a lot of the time
and you would be making love to her
while pregnant nine months out of the
year you're making love to her while
pregnant
and then two months she's probably got
to heal up from that [ __ ] and then she
gets pregnant again
and then you have make love to her
pregnancy so most of her life she
probably was pregnant biologically
speaking
you're more adaptive at making love to
your pregnant spouse
than you are to her not pregnant oh my
god back in the day when you're having a
bunch of kids over and over
this is a great point pregnancy porn is
actually more normal
this is a great point now some might say
we're not supposed to be sexually
attracted to pregnant women because it's
a waste of [ __ ]
now potentially i've heard that there
are studies that say that
husbands are mostly attracted to their
women when they are pregnant why
envy what well dj emmy likes [ __ ]
pregnant [ __ ]
yeah you said that being said maybe
you're most attractive to your wife
because you want to protect her the most
because she needs that to survive yeah
because you understand oh she's carrying
my child that's what i want biologically
that being said
there's no way that god or evolution or
whatever it is would allow you to waste
come but we switched it up socially
speaking so now we want to [ __ ] with no
consequences
what is the least consequential [ __ ] is
pregnancy
yo that's not biological mark is making
good points
america's making good points that being
said biologically speaking i think it is
a waste of your come and therefore your
body would reject it it doesn't like
waste income
and it doesn't care the same reason why
we're not attracted to super old old old
women they're no longer fertile
a pregnant woman is just as infertile
as an old woman so therefore we should
not be attracted to them but i don't
think it's a binder i think it's
probably a spectrum
say again i think it's a spectrum i
think you said that to not lose an
argument
why would i ever say that why would i
ever say something i think so too yeah
it's not binary it's not binary it's a
spectrum so that's why privacy porn is
not the most popular porn but it is a
subset that isn't inherently like the
grossest thing to me
yeah well why are our girls repulsive
when they're on that period
i see the pregnancy point but how come
our girls go through our instagrams mark
how come they see who we're following
these dumb [ __ ] you stupid sex workers
yeah that's he's more like a personal
vendetta so
is the jury out did we show the picture
of her yet or the video of her yet
women can get pregnant on their period
no they could
really if three dudes show up to your
house on announce your girl pregnant
they're [ __ ] angels
[Laughter]
no but for real you can't get pregnant
on your period yeah you stop it yeah you
can't
your girl is literally a prenatal nurse
she knows better
yeah you cannot get pregnant on your
period your period is the absence of
pregnant
no it's not yes it is you can't get
pregnant on pre-cum you can't be
pregnant on your period
you can't get pregnant on saturday why
are we dressed out on the pregnant on
the period thing
oh who got more girls pregnant than al i
want more
and he never did on their period because
he's repulsed
we now we're doing all facts no feelings
dummies okay go
can you get pregnant on your period the
simple answer is
the yes answer is no
you can't all right but blood blocks it
no you can't they can't swim in blood
it's tough maybe the sperm is as
repulsive as al is and it just swims
away
it might swim back up on your dick and
that's why [ __ ] goes to the left
because it's it's looking forward
and then it's like ew blood it just goes
against the side wall that could be it
that could be it that could be true
you